il y a un an les sourires étaient de
mise tout comme l'optimisme de la
chancelière allemande
j'ai l'impression après la rencontre
d'aujourd'hui qu'il ya une bonne volonté
de résoudre des questions difficiles et
cette bonne volonté fait partie de la
solution de tous les problèmes
politiques donc dans ce sens je peux me
permettre de dire qu'en dépit de tous
les problèmes que nous constatons je
suis satisfaite de la rencontre
aujourd'hui à l'époque déjà les
dirigeants réunis à paris pour ce sommet
au format normandie se rendent bien
compte qu'il reste du chemin à parcourir
mais cette rencontre à l'elysée permet
alors d'espérer des avancées concrètes
un an plus tard que reste-t-il des
ambitions affichées dans la capitale à
en croire les récents échanges entre les
chefs de la diplomatie russe et
française
la situation est au point mort la russie
a réaffirmé la nécessité de mettre en
oeuvre de bonne foi les décisions
mentionnées pour régler le conflit dans
le sud est de l'ukraine en s'appuyant
sur les accords de minsk du 12 février
sergueï lavrov a noté le caractère
inadmissible des tentatives de paris et
de berlin de défendre les autorités de
kiev dans leur aspiration à désavouer
les accords de minsk pour moscou
l'attitude de paris et berlin constitue
un frein dans les avancées sur le
dossier ukrainien
il ya par exemple cette réunion de l'onu
organisé le 2 décembre dernier
prévu pour aborder la mise en oeuvre des
accords de minsk cette réunion a réuni
les représentants des républiques
populaires de donetsk de lougansk ainsi
que de la russie à l'onu
mais ni l'ukraine ni la france et
l'allemagne n'ont daigné y participer
une absence souligné par le représentant
permanent de la russie au conseil de
sécurité de l'onu vassili dementia ce
qui est survenu aujourd'hui compromet le
rôle de berlin et de paris en tant que
médiateur dans le règlement de la crise
ukrainiennes moscou reproche notamment à
paris et berlin une forme de partialité
dans le dossier ukrainien en étant trop
proche des positions de kiev
une attitude qui pourrait selon moscou
fragiliser la tenue de nouveaux sommets
au format normandie les prochains mois
seront donc cruciaux pour faire évoluer
les discussions
et pour ne pas faire totalement
disparaître l'optimisme affiché à paris
en décembre 2010